up
haha
if you're going out someone I'm going
out with someone too I'll feel sorry for
me finish this drink but I much rather
be somewhere if you laugh loud a conv a
driving round on Saturday night make fun
of me singing my song Kiyoshi Terry
walls I pick me up at 3am fighting with
your mom again and I'd go go go
somewhere with you I started you to take
februari of 2010 so it's been just over
29 fears there's a song that was being
remade couple year the world and a bunch
of celebrities were getting together for
the Haiti project and that was really
cool idea and then friend of mine was
like hey we should totally do that as
because I was working with a puter
people brought all my friends together
we kind of did a remake put it out the
day before this is one dropped in
February 2010 with the remake with all
the celebrities and it was like the most
searched for video in youtube history at
the time and mine is like number two
underneath it I was like oh my gosh
that's interesting so I started just
covering a bunch of popular songs
thinking as a way to market like me as a
brand or whatever and then about a year
and a half later started integrating a
lot of original music and so now that's
kind of a focus and what's an original
stuff came out it was like all right or
with this and then play some covers here
and there and yeah just kind of went
full steam ahead and it worked my
original stuff is just like pop rap
music I'm stuff with good melodies and
organic like instrumentation but because
I'm a producer I love like work with all
types of music it's like I love hip-hop
i lo like rap stuff and I love classical
stuff and I love I feel like YouTube is
a cool space where you can like throw
anything and everything out there and if
it works it sticks and but if it doesn't
work I goes away have come up something
new so people aren't like oh you know
pigeon afford something
for me as a Brandon as like tyler ward
it's like pop rock music just could all
feel good single on you know driving the
car put on khatoon type music that's a
genre youtube has been huge popping for
a lot of different people and it's
creating careers for a lot of musicians
who would never have opportunities
around I don't know if you wanted the
screen say yes okay it's absolutely
important and I think it's a lot more
efficient now than it used to be and I
think it's smart to do videos on youtube
if you don't have any videos on YouTube
put some out especially if you're a
musician I'm going out with someone too
I'll feel sorry for me finish this drink
but I'm a travel fee else you left alone
a carnival ride a drive around on
saturday night make for me sing my song
kehoe times to tell you arms and take me
up at 3am if i can move your mom again
and i'd go go somewhere you son I'll
outside your house wait for oh my
gosh I'm collaborate a lot of YouTube
artists right now i'm working with kurt
hugo schneider we're going to Chester
see Tiffany Alvord Megan Nicole and
interested of some Lindsey Stirling and
that's all just this week which is cool
the great they're great they're all
great and I just I'm very fortunate able
to work with such down to people and in
almost in a sense like change up their
sound a little bit with the little
production I can do it or whatever
that's been really fun when you're being
musicians all I wants the focus more
like narcissistic I guess you'd say it's
like the focus is on you you got a TM
you're performing you're entertaining
people so and as a producer you're
behind the scenes you get to create
music and create parts and help our
other artists you know become better or
reach their potential and help them
sound veterans like that so it's more of
the creation process behind the scenes
is producer and then as an artist you're
more upfront and entertaining I've
always not like you know it's like more
the more people that work on a project
that are good I feel like you get more
done and it I don't know it just it just
makes sense like when you come back to a
channel and you see something different
you know the same fans are going to
appreciate you but they're going to find
something new and it just keeps them
coming back like oh that's cool that's
different it's not the same thing over
and over
and so it's more it's more entertaining
for people head allows me to just like
help others which I when that's all said
and done I just want to be able to like
grab some kids were talented help them
fulfill like what they want to do is is
a dreamlike and then just you know like
it's like a motherly instinct I guess
you'd say which I'm not a mother will
never be like a father I don't I okay
anyways besides the point I just love
working with towns of people helping
them it's awesome welcome to my crib
there's not much here but you know what
it's a strong and sturdy van if you ever
need a ride I got you thanks for coming
see ya
ok
if you see so we've been on this
shooting off about eight hours they work
as hard here it's a lot
me singing my song
I
I've been touring over the last year for
life so I was gone half the year and
four months so it's like eight months
over the last like 13 or 14 months it's
actually just yells views and the people
like come to life like they come to your
shows and you get to meet them and hear
their stories that's a really special
they just traveling the world you're
like I never thought I'd be in Italy
playing a show or you kidding me so it's
or Amsterdam London and it's like whoa
these places it's experience them
without music I wouldn't do that it's
incredible when i get on tour this is
this is what Ivan think about a lot
lately in the back of my van were just
like kind of lay down hoping to get to
the next city safely um on tour there's
a lot of a lot of kids who come come to
you or like yo like your song really
would help me through this part when I
think they would tell me a story like I
used to my gosh this girl it's
incredible so a year and a half ago she
came to a show I hugged her SR and we
took a picture together a year later in
Chicago just about two months ago she
came to show and she's like a hug girls
like hey what's going on and I didn't
recognize her at all um I would have
recognized her promise she can she
know you know we know each other okay no
we don't know until house I've never
seen you before she is like no no wait
we know each other she goes I've lost
100 pounds since last time you saw me
and it's because of you working as hard
as you do and doing what you love to do
that I felt like if you can do it and I
can do it and it was absolutely
incredible and she's showing a picture
of us since I recognize this girl so
stories like that are very very
inspiring and it's like motivating and
it's like what I'm doing is affecting
people whether it's like a super small
scale or something like that like we're
reaching and touching people and be able
like in like still I stop some
positivity or some hope or some
inspiration so that's this what inspires
me is being able to just like connect
with people
all that you don't know what you that's
awesome let me down in my national life
hold on me and if you decide
I can I love
you can do home
just
so
if you see me on the tongue and it looks
like it done you won't i won't say hello
Oh
buddy
we're close
with you
you
hey guys thank you so much for checking
out this interview if you want to check
out the written copy of this interview
can go to New Media rockstars calm and
also see some amazing photos oh my gosh
they're so going to take a photo so
check them out and go to youtube.com /
Tyler music too because that'll be cool
okay have a good day please